prince harry and meghan markle's
children archie and lilibeth recently
visited their grandfather prince charles
and a source tells e.t it was emotional
for him this was a very emotional
meeting and very very lovely for the
words used to describe this i think that
prince charles has waited a long time to
meet his granddaughter lily bert and of
course it's a long time since he's seen
archie so i think it was emotional and
very lovely the private visit took place
when megan and harry and their two kids
made a trip to the uk earlier this month
to celebrate queen elizabeth's platinum
jubilee
it was archie's first time back in
england and a very first trip for lily
since their parents stepped away from
their royal duties and moved to the
states so the family made time for a few
reunions which included a private visit
with charles and his wife camilla we
have had confirmation from a senior
palace aide to confirm that a meeting
did take place and that this was a
meeting that charles has really looked
forward to for many many months
a source tells et that since charles
hasn't seen archie for a while it was
very special to have some time with him
charles hasn't seen archie for well over
a year and of course with the pandemic
and it made traveling very very
difficult so this was a very long
overdue meeting there have been
opportunities of course
for charles to see archie over zoom but
this was the first meeting in many many
months when he actually got to see his
grandson in the flesh this also marked
the very first time he met lily and our
source says the meeting for charles was
very emotional and a very wonderful
thing people i don't think realize just
how much charles loves being a
grandfather he plays quite an active
role with the cambridge children and i
think he feels he's really missed out on
having that experience with lily beth
and archie so although it was only um it
was only one meeting we understand i
think it's very much the hope that as he
repairs his relationship with harry and
with megan he's going to get more time
with his grandchildren which he's very
much hoping for now it seems all these
reunions are a positive step in mending
the relationship between the family and
moving forward is what prince charles
wants to do i do know that charles
absolutely wants to start healing that
fractured relationship with harry i was
told by a source very close to him that
he loves his son that he will forgive
his son for everything and that he wants
to repair that relationship and move on
and i think a big part of that is also
wanting to get to be a grandfather and
see those grandchildren it may mean a
few more transatlantic trips but he
wants to enjoy those experiences
[Music]
you